вітаємо вас це програму фокусіропи від
телекомпанії Deutsche Welle
таліби рік тому в Афганістані вони взяли
владу у свої руки картини драматичних
днів закарбувалися у пам'яті батюхи з
нас
тисячі афганців стрімголов намагалися
покинути країну щоб встигнути на один із
небагатьох евакуаційних рейсів
деякі в розпачі чіплялися на літаки
міжнародні в тому числі німецькі
рятувальні літаки Лише кілька днів
виконували тоді рейси і вивезли людей із
країни
після виведення міжнародних військ
Афганістан перебуває в руках талібану
ситуація сьогодні катастрофічна народ
бідує медично обслуговування ледь
животіє особливо це погано для дітей
зокрема 11-річного Абдула який втратив
обидві руки благодійну організація
International намагається допомогти вона
привозить таких дітей яка Абдул який
потребують термінової медичної допомоги
до оббергаузена в Німеччині ми
супроводжували Абдула під час його
поїздки
вони сподіваються отримати медичну
допомогу в Німеччині заради цього сотня
афганських батьків та їхніх дітей
приїхали до кабулу також і Абдул та його
батько 11-річний хлопчик втратив обидві
руки під час бомбового удару він майже
не бачить на ліве око
благодійна організація freedence
International з Німеччини його єдиний
шанс отримати медичну допомогу
я був вже в багатьох лікарнях але там
вони мене не вилікували
тому я тут бо мені потрібно допомога для
моїх рук
Клаудія Пет Мюллер літає довганістану
багато років а вона та її колеги
відбирають важко поранених дітей таких
як Абдул для лікування в Німеччині
спеціальна працівниця зауважує що після
приходу до влади талібів рік тому
ситуація в країні різко погіршилася
А за час нашої роботи ми ніколи не
бачили що приходило стільки сімей було
понад 2200 сімей і досить важко казати
їм що хтось піде раніше а хтось пізніше
коли ти не знаєш особливо у випадку із
запаленням кісток чи буде дитина ще жива
через півроку
в Афганістані обвалилася економіка
багато людей голодують
кваліфіковані лікарі покинули країну як
і багато благодійних організацій
А зараз діти знову приходять до нас без
ментів і Уявіть собі вони не отримують
знеболювальне Ми бачили важко поранених
дітей яких у Німеччині лікували б у
відділенні інтенсивної терапії а тут
вони просто лежали вдома без
знеболювальних засобів і без банців щоб
допомогти дітям клаудії Пет Мюллер та її
колегам необхідне сприяння талібів бо
без їхньої згоди та дійсних паспортів
дітям заборонено виїжджати з країни
в той же час слід сказати що таліби
домінують у кожній сфері тобто чоловіки
які належать до цієї організації
Ми отримали абсолютно позитивний досвід
ми були навіть вражені проханням про
допомогу
благодійна організація вже майже 40
років поспіль доставляє чартерними
рейсами до Німеччини відібраних важко
поранених і хворих дітей до чужої країни
далеко від своїх батьків братів і сестер
А хто вона
Як її ім'я скажи
орзо
через кілька місяців ми знову
зустрічаємо Абдула у freedencedor в
international абобергаузені Він живе тут
разом із іншими важко пораненими дітьми
із кризових зон і зомб бойових дій з
усього світу біда зібрала їх докупи а
поки тривають операції та реабілітації
огляд рани помічниця лікаря яка лікує
Абдула пояснює йому терапію
а це є ЦУМ скамфа imagine коли він
прибув до нас кілька місяців тому в
області грудної клітки ще була рана і ми
змогли витягти багато невеликих
інкапсольованих шматків металу після
чого рана досить добре зажила
на Абдула ще чекає операція
під час тієї операції розділять ліктьову
та променеву кістки
і вставлять їх так щоб у нього було
передпліччя схоже на ножиці після чого
він зможе хапати ручку або фіксувати
інші предмети
Абдул знає що операції є для нього
великим шансом
Я не боюся я щасливий що мене
прооперують Я взагалі не боюся
радо дозволяє забути про білі війну та
Тулу за сім'єю у freedenced в
international усі діти тимчасово стають
однією командою разом із працівниками
благодійної організації і кожен вносить
свій досвід
Я вважаю що це чудово що діти щодня
показують мені наскільки дорогоцінним є
життя вони показують використовують день
живий сьогодні насправді вони не такі як
ми ми схильні думати про пенсію а в них
цього немає а вони дуже чітко говорять
тобі сьогодні максимум завтра ти можеш
над чимось задуматись але також Радій
життю
[музика]
Абдул ще не знає коли він зможе знову
повернутися довганістану але він уже
зараз радіє що покаже батькові на що він
знову здатний
Європа знову переживає незвичайну
спекотний та посушливе літо особливо на
півдні континенту спостерігаються
апокаліптичні сцени лісові пожежі засухи
пересохлі річки
столиця Греції Афіни вважається однією з
найспекотніших на континентів влітку
проте Люди там хочуть щось змінити тому
в Афінах зараз є уповноважена зі спеки
До речі перша в Європі воно має багато
ідей щодо того як можна покращити життя
понад 3 мільйонів жителів Афін
немилосердно почасонцем
розпали літа в Афінах це означає що
температура Все частіше підіймається до
відмітки 40 градусів
тест на витривалість як для туристів так
і для афінін
[музика]
зелені мерівілі завжди під рукою пляшка
води
вона обізнана зі спекою своєму місті та
з усіма небезпеками
позаяк вона є начальницею із
теплопостачання перша уповноважена зі
спеки в Афінах і Європі її завдання
підготувати місто до наслідків зміни
клімату
для цього вона спускається під землю
разом із працівником Афінської
водопровідної станції
глибини історії міста там проходить
акведук Адріана підземний тунель
довжиною майже 20 кілометрів побудований
Римським імператором адріаном у другому
столітті
Мері Віллі планує що незабаром тут знову
буде текти вода інженери вже працюють
над її ідеєю
а вони планують 20 місць А звідки можна
буде забирати воду заквидука щоб
розподіляти її по зелених насадженнях
Зелений пояс через усе місто покликаний
зробити Афіни прохолоднішими та
зеленішими
мире Віллі хоче більше парків у своєму
рідному місті одним із них 61-річна
жінка пишається особливо її знайомий
Садівник розбив його за японським
зразком
для цих парків Ми повинні вибрати
спеціальні дерева які мають багато
ціннистого листя і товстий стовбур і не
потребують багато води тому можуть
виживати в екстремальних погодних умовах
екстремальні хвилі спеки в Греції
останніми роками майже завжди
супроводжувалися лісовими пожежами які
загрожують також і столиці
всередині липня палав вогонь на
північний околиці Афін жертвами полум'я
стали десятки будинків
елені марівілі знає що час підганяє
через кілька десятиліть великі частини
чотирьохмільйонного міста можуть стати
непридатними для проживання
у літні місяці Афіни вже зараз є
найспекотнішим містом Європи
у нас майже немає парків зелених зон
водночас У нас багато бетонного та
асфальтного покриття що нагрівають місто
до цього додається відпрацьований тепло
від автомобільного транспорту та
кондиціонерів А ще ми є все більш
старіючим суспільством ця смертельна
суміш для Фін
Дослідження показали що під час хвиль
спеки помирають багато людей літнього
віку тому уповноважена зі спеки
звертається за порадами до Червоного
Хреста
представниці Червоного Хреста з
Австралії розповідають як вони там
допомагають при температурах до 50
градусів за допомогою власної системи
екстреної допомоги
вона почала працювати після великої
хвилі спеки коли померло багато людей
наші люди повинні допомогти тим хто є в
групі ризику перш ніж їм стане погано
їх слід навчити як можна себе захистити
і якщо через екстремальну погоду їм
погірше то має бути хтось умови не
зможуть зателефонувати
але дуже мало афінян сприймають цю
проблему серйозно і вважають її загрозою
для життя
якщо у мене паморочиться голова або мене
нудить то я просто занурюю ноги в
холодну воду
стає нестерпнішим нас немає жодної річки
і більша частина Території навколо міста
вже спалено
цей чоловік страждає від зміни клімату і
не тільки тому що він любить бігати на
довгі дистанції а Гіс Еммануїл є одним
із найвідоміших кліматичних активістів
Греції
що агітувати за захист клімату чоловік
пройшов Минулого року дві з половиною
тисячі кілометрів від Афін до
всесвітньої кліматичної конференції у
шотландському Глазго
Він вважає що уповноважена зі спеки це
непогана ідея але для афінці заходи є
ймовірно застарілими
Було б добре якби Через два-три роки
моєму районі з'явився парки з фонтаном
Де я зможу охолодитися
Але мені здається це як таблетка
Аспірину для онкохворого
Я боюся що ми змирилися з кліматичною
кризою тепер змушені якось адаптуватися
до неї
не хоче відмовлятися від рідного міста
але вона може зрозуміти молодих афінян
які шукають альтернативи
Моя донька навчається зараз у Норвегії і
чесно кажучи я дуже рада що вона там
живе оскільки я справді хвилююся що в
майбутньому тут На півдні буде досить
важко
але молоді афіні не повинні мати
майбутнє у рідному місті каже елені
мерівілі
зрештою Це не перша криза за майже 4000
років історії цього міста
[музика]
впродовж місяців бореться зі спекою та
посухою також Італією запаси води
скорочуються простріл від жилю є ще одна
проблема багато туристів хоча Вони
приносять острову гроші але також
використовують дуже багато води тому
певна річ що її слід брати звідти де
вона є як здається в необмеженій
кількості а саме з моря опіснювальний
завод на джилію щодня виробляє мільйони
літрів прісної води але й викликає
багато Роздратування
якби це можна було просто пити
[музика]
так морською води на Джиллі на південний
схід від ельби багато
Джерельної води вистачало на столітті
але з туризмом попит на воду неймовірно
зріс
влітку чисельність населення на джилію
збільшується у 10 разів і тому острову
необхідно ця опріснювальна установка
щодня з морської води тут виробляють до
двох мільйонів літрів прісної води
вода закачується з моря і потрапляє у ці
два резервуари
а в цих циліндрах вода спочатку
фільтрується
щоб у її більше не було бактерій чи
інших мікроорганізмів які можуть потім
викликати проблеми під час очищення
потім відфільтрована вода поступає у ці
білі труби і проходить під високим
тиском через мембрану
сіль залишається та витікає прісна вода
добре дуже добре
звучить просто чому можна Саме так
розв'язати проблему води у багатьох
місцях біолог Андрея белуськийо каже у
пріснення має підводні камені він та
його колеги вивчають морське дно біля
Джиллі вже понад 10 років також і
навколо опріснювальної станції
Ось там розсілись заводу потрапляє у
море
там за скелями де з'являється піна
луг у три рази солоніший за звичайну
морську воду
біологи виявляють що в радіусі майже 30
метрів рослини загинули
також і нептунова трава яка має
вирішальне значення для водного балансу
для порівняння Ось так виглядає здорове
морське дно біля джим'ю
к
має те саме значення що ліс на землі
Вона стабілізує ґрунт
Вона виробляє кисень і служить притулком
для риб та багатьох інших істот
ці морські ліси є справжньою екосистемою
навколо зони стічних вод зникли також її
більшість тварин
опіснювальний завод має ще більше
проблем він споживає стільки
електроенергії як 500 домогосподарств із
трьох осіб
енергія надходить із самого острова а з
іншого боку
електрику виробляють за допомогою
генераторів
[музика]
Це завод з виробництва електроенергії на
іншому боці острова
тільки для опріснювальної установки тут
спалюються близько тисячі літрів
дизельного палива щодня Невже немає
альтернативи
мер пояснює нам багато будинків є
історичними і про встановлення на них
сонячних панелей не може бути і мови
більше частина острова є природним
заповідником тому жодних вітрових турбін
з виробництва електроенергії заводиться
багато тонн дизельного палива
Але існує національний проєкт
через силовий кабель острів мають
під'єднати до материкової мережі
коли буде початок проекту поки невідомо
Отже далі з дизпаливом оскільки хороший
альтернативи опрісненню немає
а для власників готелів зокрема Єви
Маріус життя без опріснювальної
установки було б неможливим
раніше воду привозив танкер
коли вона закінчувалась мої дідусі
бабуся були вимушені спускатись
вниздогавані щоб набрати води з криниці
з такими способом а завдяки
обрізнювальній установці в нас більше
ніколи не було проблеми з водою
однак біолог Андрея белуський вважає що
в постійному постачанні прісної води
приховується небезпека
через наявність опріснювального заводу
вода витрачається марно перший душ після
купання потім другий третій у Гавані
кораблі оприскують прісною водою
опіснювальну установку мають незабаром
модернізувати тоді вона зможе виробляти
ще більше води
що означає також більш розсолу і ще
більше споживання дизпалива
тож існує лише один засіб ущадливо
використовувати дорогоцінний ресурс воду
не знати чи ще жива твоя дитина Євгенія
та Олександр Буткевич переживають цю
невизначеність уже багато тижнів поспіль
їхній син вирішив протистояти російським
загарникам у війні яка триває вже майже
півроку
і в якій є не лише загиблі та поранення
але полонені
Максим один із мабуть понад 7 тисяч
українських військових у російському
полоні
І батьки воліють не уявляти що з ним там
може трапитися
Євгенія Буткевич щоранку проводить
кілька хвилин із фотографією сина
Максима в руці вона нічого не чула про
нього відтоді як два місяці тому він
потрапив у російський полон або на
боїться що його катують або що він уже
можливо мертвий плакати
а чоловік ще спить
а потім він просинається А я вже все я
вмилася і в мене почався день все я
більше намагаюсь не плакати оце тільки
вранці дозволяє собі
Євгенія та Олександр буткевича запросили
нас щоб розповісти про свого сина Максим
Буткевич пішов добровольцем до армії
роками український журналіст та активіст
виступав за права людини та біженців
коли Росія напала на Україну Максим
вирішив боротися за свою країну кажуть
батьки
він антимілітарист так він пацифіст за
своєю сутністю за своєю природою а тому
що він сказав що я йду до армії тому що
маю захистити такі цінності заради яких
я все своє життя беру все Бо якби ми
були молодші мабуть пішли А ми вже не
можемо а він може про те що Максим
потрапив у полон батьки дізналися лише
завдяки відео опублікованому в
російських державних ЗМІ на якому видно
як їхнього сина допитують десь у підвалі
на точку встречи Це був жах перше щоб
мене було це жах
я дивилась на свою дитину і думали Цього
не може бути
упродовж наступних тижнів близький до
Кремля соціальні медіа неодноразово
називали Максима нацистом
ультранаціоналістом і навіть британським
шпигуном просто тому що він працював
продюсером на BBC У 2003 році батьки
звернулись до військових внутрішньої
розвідки гуманітарних організацій але
ніхто нічого не зміг їм сказати
Найбільше це непокоєння якраз полягає в
тому що його можуть висмикнути із
середовище міського полонених
і
зфабрикувати справу
за політичною статтею за якоюсь
політично кримінальною саме
використовуючи оці свої фейки від одного
джерела у внутрішній розвідці ми
дізнались що в російському полоні
перебувають понад 7 тисяч українців
органи безпеки намагаються зібрати
якомога більше інформації
але ця робота секретна тож наші запити
на інтерв'ю відхиляють Утім один адвокат
який представляє інтереси 50 сімей
військовополонених готовий поговорити з
нами Владислав ігнатьєв тісно співпрацює
з внутрішньою розвідкою що повернути
полонених Він вважає що в майбутньому
Росія переслідуватиме все більше
полонених українських військових як
нацистів або за інший нібито злочини
Я вважаю що це політичні маневри
висуваючи такі звинувачення вони роблять
людину ціннішою стверджуючи наприклад що
це важливий нацист
щоб використати це потім у політичних
переговорах
де батьки Максима не хочуть щоб справа
зайшла Так далеко і терміново подали
заяву до Європейського Суду з прав
людини
щоб так чинити тиск на Росію забезпечити
міжнародним організаціям доступ до
їхнього сина
А ще очікування Що це допоможе знайти
Максима в нас тільки одна мета Все що ми
робимо ми тільки одну мету знайти
Максима і його побратимів
А до того часу Євгенія та Олександра
буткевича намагаються залишатись
сильними навіть якщо час від часу страх
і паніка беруть над ними гору
Віталій велосипеди вже давно вважаються
радше спортивним інвентарем ніж засобом
пересування Але зараз в Україні Ferrari
фіату та вести Що змінюється двоколісний
транспорт як засіб пересування набирає
обертів особливо на півночі країни
найкращий приклад там подає місто ферара
що ж тоді щасливої дороги Це була
програма фокусі Європи і телекомпанії
Deutsche Welle Дякуємо за вашу
зацікавленість більше інформації ви
знаєте як завжди в інтернеті На все
добре до побачення
[музика]
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціативи переклад Володимира та Олесі
Швед режисер Павло Тимченко так читали
Олена потоцька Юрій Лисенко та Олесь
гоян Київ 2022 рік
[музика]